- Jordan Klepper, here,
at the Opposition.
We're taking a well
deserved break this week
because sometimes the most
productive thing you can do
is take some time off
to think, to pray.
But, we're not the only
ones taking a breather.
The NRA has also gone completely
silent since yesterday
for some, I don't
know, unknown reason.
And these guys love
to talk, tweet, bait,
aggressively attack
and especially donate
to some of our favorite
members of Congress.
Like these folks,
love these guys.
Now, I'm glad you guys
are takin' a break.
You work so hard,
you do so much.
I mean, honestly, how do
you have time to sleep?
I mean, seriously, NRA
how do you sleep at night?
How?
With everything
that's happening,
how do you even sleep?
Our show returns on
Tuesday and, ya know,
maybe the NRA will be
back tweetin' by then too.
Ya hear that NRA?
As far as I'm concerned,
you guys are a bunch a
see you next Tuesdays.
The fight continues.
You, are you a deep
state operative
sent by George Soros to take
away my second amendment rights
and force feed me soy burgers?
No.
Well then, prove it.
Click and subscribe and
join the Opposition now.